hello
hey is this real
can you guys hear me
hey okay this is real
nice
hi there welcome i made some pancakes
for the occasion
i hope you all did too
wow thanks everyone good to see you this
is really cool
i've never done a live stream so this is
like um
really weird so i don't if if i like
mess up with the whole like uh
stuff going on because i don't know how
to multitask and i'm probably just gonna
be eating pancakes
um that might be a problem
but so far
seems like it's going okay um thank you
okay
all right i need to hi everyone i'm
recognizing all these names
roryn
david hey david oh my god
this is awesome thanks everyone for
being here um
we're you know we're just gonna have
okay you have beer
that's cool how do i highlight uh can i
highlight
pinned messages i don't know anyways
um yeah welcome we're just going to
chill
have some pancakes and um
that's that's kind of how it's going to
go thank you
thank you hi
you have a beer too okay i should
probably get a i guess i could
i could get a root beer maybe but um
yeah so i just kind of wanted to check
in and say hi to everybody
i want to thank um everyone who is here
and who has subscribed and supported the
channel because
it has been um really really um
fun and crazy and important and you know
i'm just very grateful for all of the
help
um yeah these pancakes do look pretty
good huh i just made them they're like
but they're like the kind you just put
water in so they're they're very simple
but don't worry don't worry we'll dive
into the pancakes in a minute
hey this is the guy who called dr brian
sanders dad hello
thanks for reminding me just an
embarrassing moment in my life
yeah not not something i always try to
remember
you should be able to click uh to
highlight a comment on the live stream
part that shows comms depending on what
platform you are using
yeah i'm just using i'm just using
youtube
i don't know
thank you when are we hoping on
fortnight for some duos i don't know
hey how's debra um come on
really do we have to talk deborah right
now
it's a it's a tricky subject
i'll just say that debra is she seems
fine
i'm happy for her how how joshua
we don't need to talk about joshua
joshua's
i assume he's okay um i try not to think
about him too much
um congrats dude i love the sanderson
life lesson videos
thank you so much um
i like those too i'm about to go through
some therapy live on stream
maybe i'm wearing black i i feel very
like
in that mood if you guys want to be my
therapists
i'm okay with that hey i mean this is
free so free therapy i mean
you guys can help me out in that way
okay pablo you're here to have fun or
die trying as per commanded
okay that's the spirit that's the
attitude thank you pablo
he is here to have fun or die trying
um half of the reason why i'm reading
the stormlight archive is to be able to
watch your sketches
that is really nice thank you
um i thought you had a fur collar for a
second
what
i mean i have one of those but i'm not
gonna put it on right now kelsier with
the machine gun is the only
thing we all didn't know we needed
that's true
wow how's michael michael my son michael
nip
i i have not michael nip but i pretend
he's my son
i guess for the sake of that i like
pablo's energy me too pablo is great if
you guys don't
uh haven't subscribed to pablo pablo
suarez go
go subscribe to him he's really
wonderful
um what's the name of your cute dog
that cameoed in the last video her name
is sedona
and um i don't know where she comes from
she just kind of wanders into my place
sometimes
um have you read the kingkiller
chronicle knit yet
um no i haven't actually i really want
to though
because i feel like i could do some some
meme
cover some meme territory with king
killer
um you love the skit uh pablo
uh and i did yeah that was fun that was
pablo's
idea he approached me and he said hey i
have this idea for the skit and i was
like
all right let's do it and
it kind of went off the rails a little
bit in terms of
my side of the shooting but i think it
worked out
um um
are you am i the guy that reviewed
donald green's wheel of
peace
yeah i am i am that was
that was that was good okay wow 86
people are here
wow hi hi 86 people this is very cool
i'm just going to be eating some
pancakes here so give me a second i'm
going to keep reading chat but i do have
to
enjoy the pancakes i mean i've i've i
slept like
three hours so i'm very hungry
all right
oh this is the really good like mapley
kind of syrup
okay watch let me see if i can do this
oh wow okay all right
yeah straight from the bottle i don't i
don't mess around
here i'll i'll squat down so you all can
see
the pancakes you guys can hear me all
right yeah
is it loud enough
okay whoa
all right lots lots going on i'm i'm
reading i'm reading
what am i reading currently um i'm
reading rhythm of war
actually um what's my name
what is my name um it's jake my name is
jake
um or jacob uh
i love you deciding what to read based
on mean potential that's pretty
like i don't even care about reading
stuff that i enjoy i just
i just if i can extract meme potential
or get some kind of views you know
that's all
just the cloud um i should read
king killer um what are your thoughts on
kelsier joining fortnite
um i am
i'm all for it i mean i'm i'm sort of
indifferent
uh apparently fortnite is a video game i
would have preferred he joined minecraft
because as you know as you all know
um when we get to 10 000 subs
keep this in mind wow i can't even read
the chat don't worry i'll get to the
chat
but when we get to 10k subs this becomes
a minecraft channel
and you know i've been very unapologetic
about it that's my goal it's
it's a sneaky goal but i feel like i go
through the
booktube channels swim up those channels
and then once i get to the other side i
become a minecraft
streamer and i just kind of like
surprise everybody
and then i feel like that's the easy way
to go because minecraft isn't that
popular you know nobody watches
minecraft videos
am i going to eat the pancakes yes i'm
sorry i will
it's going to be weird though
okay the the communist manifesto has the
ultimate meme potential
yeah it does actually good point
hi my dream is to publish a book and
have you make meme videos about it oh
that's sweet
i you know what if you have a book
published
i'll make a meme man carrying a stack of
flappy jacks
is that what we call it flappy jacks
would you suggest blade runner as an
intro to science fiction i think so it's
been a while since i've seen blade
blade runner but it's a great movie
um what is the book's name that you are
currently reading what you uh so i'm
reading rhythm of war right now
[Music]
um because i took a slight break
break from stormlight but um
yeah it's it's good i i like it so far
it's a
okay sound quality is good height reveal
i'm kind of reading backwards up the
chat i'm sorry height reveal i'm
actually 6'3
um
imagine the potential of a minecraft
stream full of book meme references
okay
how many in which dan brown books have
you read i haven't read any dan brown
books i would like to i just haven't
gotten around to it which ones should i
read
mark says hey wait is this man carrying
thing or man carrying
i i screwed it up i'm sorry mark or man
streaming thing
am i right all right that's my comedy
set done that was good but i screwed it
up i'm sorry mark
miscellaneous goblin is here who is that
calvin or hobbes the spare drum room
says calvin or hobbes
i forget which is which uh my man that
was the best possible answer
i think i love you
wow somebody loves me
that's that's different it's nice
uh minecraft is also a video yeah
mbti type yes thank you for asking i
love this question
and okay the chat is going fast i'm
trying to um
you know keep going but i'm kind of i go
down to the bottom and then i read up i
don't know why i'm doing that it's just
i've never done this before so
my mbti type iron blah blah blah i am
infp
okay calvin is the war criminal and
hobbs is the other war criminal
okay people usually forget calvin and
hobbes were at nuremberg
okay
yeah can i just eat the pan i'm so sorry
guys i'll eat the pancakes it's like
getting
like cold but it's like getting sad
i'm just gonna eat the whole should i
eat the whole pancake vote should i eat
the whole pancake just like this
stick it in my mouth
i'm gonna do it yeah
okay all right
okay i'm gonna
okay someone said no
okay um
oh my god
wow
yeah cringe i know i know it's cringe
but what wow
okay i can't read everything but i'm
just i'm going through
yes i made jake laugh my work here is
done for sure
um all right
now i want pancakes yeah you guys should
make pancakes pam pancakes are so good
oh my god yeah so i'm infp which
basically means i have
deeply deep emotional problems
um fun fact i'm married to an intj
which is interesting because we're very
uh
we we're very different i i'm like pure
not
logic as you could tell by the kind of
videos i make it's just
absolutely no logic
and she is very logical so um you know
blueberry pancakes are where it's at i
disagree
i disagree um i could never tell if the
joshua thing is real or just made up for
fun he seems real
he he seems real i'm sure there are some
people named joshua in the world and i
do feel bad for them
but this particular joshua the one who
stole my wife
yeah being an intj is hell on earth
yeah um okay
fair enough um sup hey pablo
pablo pablo's the best um
have i started wheel of time no no sorry
i have not started yet um
when are we gonna see our judge judy
lawsuit against the myspace content
creator daniel green
soon um
i i didn't know daniel green was on
myspace but i'm you know good for him
uh banana pancakes banana pancakes are
good actually
i'm married to darkness wow
okay how many times has brendan frazier
made you read warbreaker
too many to count he's always bugging me
brian sanders isn't real nor is brandon
sanderson
really i guess so does my
real wife like to read real wife
sure um no that she does she she reads a
lot
she likes thrillers um
okay fun fun fact i'm i'm reading rhythm
of war right now
and she's like i want to read rhythm of
war and i go
um okay well you should read the way of
kings first and all the other stormlight
books first and she's like no i just
want to start with rhythm of war
and i'm like
why like what is the point
um yo your stuff is hilarious dude thank
you joseph
one time i made mandarin orange pancakes
okay
brandon sanderson killed my daughter
no oh god i'm really sorry about that
um does my fake wife like to read
no um i'm with pablo nothing is real
thank you um brandon sanderson ate my
son
congratulations thank you
how am i feeling about rhythm of war so
far i really love um
the momentum in the beginning i think
everyone's kind of talked about how it
has that great momentum
i read oath i finished oathbringer a
while ago so
uh it was nice getting like a nice
momentum push
into it um
you just started stormlight congrats and
i'm your 250 pages
in and dalinar is a bad
a word yeah he is you don't even know
until you've read oathbringer
how bad he is um
when are we starting fortnite okay this
is a minecraft channel
all right i'm sorry like fortnite yeah
they got
their own thing but this is this is pure
minecraft guys
um how do i come up with video ideas
um absolute like lack of sleep
not joking i will be up like full nights
usually every day at post i'm like up
the whole night
because i'm just like have a cheese
grater
against my head because i don't plan
anything in advance and i'm just very
stupid about it
i really need to have better scheduling
recreate my profile pic and when are you
joining
uh uh when am i joining what where where
did it go
i'm sorry i you showed your girlfriend
your
yazna stormlight sketch um
the moment she told me she'd read that
section thank you
i um i like that one the the yazdal one
yazna is a character that i i love and
hate because i feel like okay she's a
badass but also
if i met her in real life i would not
really want to talk to her at all
currently halfway through way of kings
congrats um
wish i could consume all the books at
once yeah i know
how i consider making a discord server
yes i have but somebody needs to teach
me how to do discord because i just
don't know
i don't know how it works
i have a foundation i haven't yet uh but
i i really want to i have that
plan um just so everyone know okay just
so everybody knows i have an exclusive
video video where i explore
why the dark sun thingy in shays mars
actually the baby sun from the
teletubbies
pablo that sounds interesting
what
um you should filter the chat to lo
to chat to live it will be slower and
you'll get some time to read the
messages
i okay i don't know how but i'll try
am i your real dad
am i your real dad that's the question
sure
yeah that's fine discord more like
dat cord okay what oh my god this is
overwhelming
who's my favorite dark tower character
father callahan
um for sure
congratulations on 5k thank you um
yes is a great character but i never
want to meet her yeah
um any other westerns like butcher's
crossing
um i recommend i just finished a really
great western called 40 lashes less
excuse me pancakes called 40 lashes less
one
by elmore leonard which is actually it
was purchased the rights were purchased
by
uh quentin tarantino some years ago so
he might do like a
mini series out of it super good dad
carrying thing
yeah i oh
i have divorced dad energy even though
i'm not divorced
can i touch your face if you can
i challenge you go for it but i don't
think you can right now
um gonna head out just wanted to say
congrats on 5k
thank you thank you so much
so excited for patreon yes thank you
thank you for mentioning that actually i
just started a patreon
uh just yeah
actually uh it was it was fun go check
it out um
just because people were asking about it
and i wanted to
put it up and uh see what happens so
patreon is up
uh the link is on my channel and the
cheers are fun
um i believe the the highest cheer you
can go is called rick
so that's there um
on a serious note congrats on 5k thank
you pablo
sora b h i am your 666th
subscriber by the way whoa that's cool
that's kind of cursed though
oh don't don't bring any uh devil energy
to the chat
um here because of the brilliant lost in
discovery yes
um cheers to lost in discovery he is
brilliant and wonderful
also i just have to say real quick it's
it seems
clear that a huge amount of
you all are here because of a certain
goblin
named daniel green so i just want to say
for the record that
thank you for being here and and i do
need to say you know thank you to daniel
green
very sincerely i know that we are you
know
pursuing legal action against each other
but um
he is wonderful and he's been he shared
my my content like crazy and been very
generous and
he's he's one of those content creators
who was actually extremely generous to
small creators so
um i'm sure you guys know that already
um tell me jake what made you come to
therapy today
my wife told me to um
hey oh my god jimmy nuts fantasy network
he is here i hope to see me on jimmy
nuts podcast one day i would love to
the couch uh is rather nice thank you
um it's it's it's very comfortable um
i sleep on it sometimes um
where would i recommend starting with
stephen king
i would read book seven of the dark
tower first
and then read the gunslinger and then
read the stand
um okay but seriously um
i would read the shining i think
your content is smart the memes too
thank you mohit um
i've never it's nobody's ever called it
smart so that's really nice thank you
so far jake's eating speed is one
pancake for 23 minutes
has it been 23 minutes oh wow
case for infinity your couch is deathly
uncomfortable i'm so sorry
i don't i mean that's hard
video's lv do you sleep on the couch
when joshua is over
wow going going right for the heart all
right
what author would i like to interview ah
man shakespeare um
your brandon lectures are the funniest
things ever thank you uh hope your son
is doing okay
he's not um loved your prose analysis
videos thank you
um that though those are i like doing
those pros analysis too
[Music]
but um they do take a lot of work and
but it's fun
i i think i'll do some more i don't know
what i don't know what authors to
analyze though
honestly i don't know who would which
ones would be interesting
um yeah jimmy nuts and man carrying
thing mash up i'm ready
jimmy is cool
if the pancakes are terrible you can
tell us then maybe we'd stop forcing you
to eat them
the pancakes are fine but i will be
perfectly honest i already had some
pancakes
um earlier so i'm just kind of being a
glutton at this point but i'll i'll keep
going i mean it's
it's fine i just need to
okay
your video on lolita was very
informative and straight to the point
thank you
um fun fun fact the lolita video was
actually a school assignment
um i because i do videos every wednesday
and saturday and my
final project was due on a wednesday and
we were supposed to do presentations and
ask my professor if uh
i could just do the um
a video and then i i just put it on my
channel and i was like a win
win win uh where's the syrup it's on
there just soaked in these are like
these like intense pancakes that are
just like
i don't know they just they just soak up
all of the
syrup i can put more on i mean i don't
know it's really sweet already but
you know there we go
um yeah also in like a few minutes i'm
going to be
getting my trumpet out so you guys can
see me play trumpet
what's my age by the way i am 23
i think i'm 23. yeah i turned 24 this
year
i'm in school yeah i'm actually i i uh
took
like a year off from college and i
jumped around schools a bit so i'm i'm a
little behind
college-wise but yeah i'm in school i go
to ucla
um
pancake abuse yeah the pancakes are
fluffy
what's the drama with daniel green if
you don't want to talk about it that's
fine i just wasn't aware something
negative was going on
yeah me and daniel green we got lawyers
involved and it's
all total [ __ ] there's actually no
drama
we are we are buddies um it's just a
joke but
it's but like canon wise
we have we have issues for no apparent
reason
play taps i i could do that
uh first law i haven't read it first law
but i i really want to read first law
i feel like joe anaconda is is the kind
of writer i would just be like
really vibing with no one has done book
asmr yet i don't think i thought about
doing that maybe like
green eggs and ham asmr
my favorite epic fantasy series probably
stormlight
uh do i remember the roshar news i did
with daniel i watched them maybe 100
times i'm obsessed
yeah that was cool that was really nice
because
um daniel reached out to me and
uh asked if i wanted to do a skit and i
was like
oh i have this idea and we wrote it
together and
yeah it was fun um
congrats on 5k thank you susan this is a
food channel now yeah probably
um from what planet
am i from that's too many froms i can't
answer that question i'm sorry sam
i should play the lick um
a 23 year old divorced dad yeah
that's that's the kind of vibe i give
off when are the minecraft let's place
jacob when i get to uh 10 000
subscribers i'll do minecraft let's
plays this is just a minecraft channel i
won't read another book
my whole life i swear to god what's my
major i'm an english major
uh digital humanities minor um
you always assumed i was older than you
and now i don't know what to think yeah
a lot of people say that i've
like ever since i was like 18 people
thought i was like
in my late 20s like early 30s and
it's i got married when i was
22 so
um yeah food channel now
hey 126 people here that's that's
awesome
um
from what planet are you from you from
joe anaconda displays young george rr
martin pick yeah that's a deep cut
um joe anaconda is cool have i read
louie lamore's book i actually just
checked out um
hondo from the library and i'm thinking
of reading that soon um
we need a discord server or subreddit
made for a man carrying thing lore yes
do i have to i think i have to make that
then um
when is the first man carrying thing
versus daniel green boxing fight soon
soon pablo anaconda's characterization
is the best out there highly recommend
yeah yeah yeah for sure um
they do have minecraft books um really
your son likes them that's cool i could
um
yeah the minecraft thing real sort of
it's kind of just a joke i i figure i'll
just do like a joke
but it's also real um
are am i currently writing anything yeah
i'm writing a fantasy novel
right now um
what's my favorite thing about booktube
people like you
jimmy you angel um
i yeah honestly the people they're
they're very nice
that's the thing like if you're
interested in doing a booktube channel i
seriously
like recommend doing that because
there's no community
as far as i know as like warm and
welcoming to to new people on booktube
um just nice internet comments like when
i first posted my
my first video i was like okay people
are gonna send me death threats like i
don't
i don't know why you just feel like the
internet is really vitriolic but when
you actually
like engage in booktube everyone is
extremely nice
and friendly um
if i could change one thing about the
stormlight archive what would it be
the length to be honest well the pacing
i guess but i mean i love the books and
part of me loves how crazy long they are
but
you know i i do i like to read other
things sometimes
um congratulations
when is the brandon sanderson disheveled
goblin man carrying things get dropping
oh super super soon um yeah well brandon
sanderson did that
um uh he did a book review
and that was really funny and um
i i'm just waiting for him to do do book
skits because those would be amazing
um is it weird that i followed you
before finding daniel green's channel
fantasy newbie here and i seem to be
falling backward into the fandom that's
really cool
um agent of malarkey that's that's
unique
um you found me before daniel green
i take that with pride a subreddit would
be great that would be fun
um any thoughts on getting brando sander
to finish the song of ice and fire or
the king killer chronicles
um if he would lift the restraining
order i would love
to tell him that uh is it true that
you've adopted every subscriber of your
channel
um almost uh anyone who asks if you want
to be adopted um
go for it um
[Music]
just the sample of minecraft books on
audible is so funny maybe i should do a
a video where i review minecraft books i
am your spirit animal
huh i think i should okay
wait
how to get rid of reader's block reading
fantasy for the first time and really
struggling at the world of ranks
yeah i totally get that um for me
personally
i some things it's you gotta just force
yourself through
and then you'll you'll appreciate it but
um
for real if you're like struggling every
day to just get through a few pages just
read something else
for a while just find what really
connects with you
that's the best thing you can do um
he brandon would make everything longer
yeah
if i could change anything in stormlight
it would be to add more suberial
agreed oh so agreed um
i like to read other things at times um
yeah i do i'm sorry um
what's cooking good looking
pancakes my thoughts on andy weir
haven't read any andy weir
uh will i ever read a song of ice and
fire absolutely i really want to
um am i responsible for the mistborn
fortnite skin
um no uh
what i i live for you butchering authors
names thank you
uh i want to be adopted roaring okay
you're adopted
are are you going to buy the sanderson
ip board game do you know about this
i think i've heard about that and um i'd
like to do that
um i like you a bit more than daniel
green
i'm gonna tweet him right now i'm gonna
say daniel green
somebody likes me more than you um
have i read meditations like
um the classic text um
why didn't i tell you you i was at an
lcm all along
i should have told you that um
have i considered doing book skits in
the styling of the office
um i wonder how that would go i could do
i guess i could do like stormlight but
it's the office
that'd be that could be interesting um
someone should clip your reaction what's
cooking good looking
yeah that yeah um i was enjoying the
witcher but my bookmark fell
out and realized i'd forgotten
everything
forgotten everything that sucks
um what's my hottest book
hot take at the moment um
i man my hottest book hot take
i actually have none i'm so sorry i
can't even think of a single one
um
i don't know about the kelsier fortnite
skin yeah i know about it i watched
ridima's um
if you guys haven't subscribed to ridima
she's she's awesome but retima
has um she did the
the meme the brandon fortnight meme
am i daniel green's long-lost brother
um maybe that might explain a lot
i thought you were daniel's wife
andy smith why won't you play fortnite
with me andy
i want to play fortnite with you i just
we nee we need to find a time i i
i would love to play fortnite but also i
don't i don't even know how to
how to work my computer but i'm going to
figure that out and then me and andy's
andy smith we're going to play fortnite
by the way andy is here
andy is great go sub subscribe to andy
smith his channel is amazing his channel
is the reason why i'm reading
malazan this year
yeah omg it's andy smith i know uh
good evening congrats with 5k thank you
is the evening where you are
uh congratulations on the finding do a
backflip
i'm eating pancakes is that not enough
this friend bonded with you what kind do
you think it would be
do a barrel are you guys just going to
keep telling me to do acrobatics
andy smith we are going to hello fellow
kids the fortnite community yeah
i know hello fellow kids i feel like
that's been my whole life
great job on the 5k mate don't know if
this has been asked but have you
had any ideas for videos around rhythm
of war
um yeah i mean it's all going to be
coming out you know rhythm of war stuff
i just need to finish it
king congratulations psy
that was that was good thank you james
the pancakes are getting cold i know
i do my laundry please
i don't even i don't even have time to
do my own laundry
it's evening in europe and probably
other places i don't know how time works
yeah where is everybody like what
countries are you are you all in
let's see daniel green is cool but i get
more excited to see a video from you oh
that well that's
that's nice dude you're going to get
arrested for neglecting your children
with the pillow behind your hand it
because it kind of looks like you have a
dyed mullet i had a mullet for a while
for real for real will i do a vlog um
yeah i think so i think i'll put vlogs
on patreon
maybe uh congrats on finishing your 5k
race
what oh i don't germany poland okay here
it comes u.s
canada it's midnight in india awesome
czech republic india oh my god germany
canada india
mordor help pablo okay oh
all right i'm watching from brazil u.s
belgium
germany netherlands england canada
ireland
welcome ireland uh chile oh
you're from the fine country of
oceanside california okay i'm in los
angeles by the way
um you're from northern california
poland brazil russia
from elantris south korea sweden that is
super cool
thank you for telling i love seeing this
because
as a someone who lives in the u.s
people in the u.s tend to tend to think
that there are no other places in the
world
you're from kansas that's not a country
okay if you ever decided if i decided
visit denmark you'll buy me a beer all
right
i really want to travel i've you know
i'm dying to travel
um yeah
okay iowa indiana norway
north korea
if you're watching me from north korea
just taking the risk just to like
be on on my stream i mean
good for you all right we're going for
another
bite where have i traveled to um
right before uh the pandemic like right
before like in january 2020
me and my wife went on it was my first
trip ever to europe we went to paris we
went to venice and we went to rome
right before the pandemic hit and um i'm
really happy we did
the 5k thing was a joke like 5k subs 5k
race i got
i get i get the joke i get i i
understood it
if i'm ever in the west midlands region
of the uk you know i'm buying you a pint
pablo thank you pablo um
[Music]
buying me a pint is that like a english
thing
i assume so
wow this pancakes are really cold guys
it's kind of sad i wish i could share it
with you all
dominican republic um
have i made a video about books and
characters that made your personality
brandon sanderson made my personality no
i haven't yet but there are some books
that are like seriously important to me
um like that came at the perfect time i
would love to talk about them at some
point
this is wholesome thank you i i try
um pablo says it's beer okay
um i feel like daniel green's holding a
gun at my head
i was gonna do a bit where i pretended
he is but i feel like that would be
but now i'll do it i'll do it please
help
is that good
we can never tell when you're joking and
serious
neither can i
not to be stereotypical but if you come
to russia i'll buy you vodka
thank you that is stereotypical but uh
so loud hey jake want to go backpacking
with me i tell joshua he can come too
joshua's not allowed to come backpacking
we don't need joshua with us
what is this joshua i feel like you guys
want to be joshua's friends sometimes
joshua literally
like did cheating on me with his wife
my wife um that's the story
what are some of those books oh did i
make pancakes myself yeah totally
i did i really did um
books that are super important to me uh
in my life light in august
moby dick i read in middle school um
east of eden
harry potter
the phantom tollbooth
i don't know there's some others who
would win in a wrestling match between
you and daniel green
i don't know i've never met him in
person so he could be like
seven feet tall and i wouldn't know and
he'd win
i could push him off a cliff while
backpacking though oh you're talking
about joshua yeah i could
dogs are cats um i'm allergic to cats
but my wife love cat loves cats and
wants me to get a cat anyway
she's like just get a cat it doesn't
matter if you have allergies the rest of
your life
um i'm only here for joshua who even are
you okay that's hurtful
is joshua moash's great grand cousin
yeah pretty much
um yes not enough people acknowledge
east of eden yeah i really love that
book
um joshua's not our guy yeah
what is one book i would like to forget
about completely to read again for the
first time pablo thank you good question
uh the great gatsby what a sad life
being allergic to cats yeah
i like cats i just get really allergic
but i have two doggies right now and
they're just perfect
okay all right so i i have to like do
something with these pancakes i'm gonna
have one more bite of pancakes then i'm
gonna get the trumpet out all right
oh wait no there's another food thing i
want to do
what do they call it mukbang when you
like eat food on camera
when does my collab with joe rogan come
out
i emailed him he hasn't gotten back to
me um
he used to be allergic to cats and
defeated
i defeated my allergies um let's see the
dogs they are they're hiding right now
but
maybe um
i bet joshua can eat more pancakes
i could eat more pancakes uh where are
you good in school
um was i good in school
for a while but then i got depressed in
high school and i just stopped
trying to be honest um
but i'm i'm pretty good now i think
uh i kind of have to be for like you
know financial aid and stuff
um this is my favorite booktube channel
this is an awesome milestone thank you
juke
um mukbang eating a ridiculous amount of
food for a camera thank you
um yeah joe only reads books about mma
yeah that's what i heard red panda hi hi
uh what is the book you're most excited
to reread oh probably uh blood meridian
um because there's a lot in there that
probably went over my head
but it was really good um
what was my favorite choose your own
adventure book never read one
uh ever will this be recorded and
available afterwards for sure yeah
100 how do i feel about the hobbit
hobbit is good i read that in middle
school i really loved the hobbit i never
saw the movies though because the hobbit
was very special to me
i didn't want to ruin it okay so on
daniel green's stream uh recently
uh we talked about snacks i i did it
with uh katherine
from ex catherine who's another
wonderful amazing channel
so we were talking about snacks and
ranking snacks and then we talked about
pocky talk about these um does anyone
know these
because we were like trashing them
because none of us had tried them but
the whole chat was like
oh you got to try them you got to try
them so i'm going to try them right now
is this do people know these snacks is
this a thing
this is making you so hungry i didn't
eat lunch yet yeah i i've eaten
so much already i'm just like being
really gluttonous today
it's all good okay they're good sister
is addicted
hello jack i'm also big brian sanders
fan
hugo hugo reads is here give it up for
hugo reeds for calling me jack
sound like joe biden right now hugo um
hugh goes great go subscribe
subscribe to hugo i love this channel um
have you come across a book that you
thought was too complex for you
oh yeah like all the time um
i've tried reading ulysses a couple
times and i've gotten
probably like 300 pages in and i just
stop
finnegan's wake is like a book that i
don't think anyone can comprehend um
i haven't read gravity's rainbow um
because it's probably a little too much
for me
um okay some people know the stack okay
if you're asian you know that's what i
thought i feel like it was more of a
very overrated overweight weeb
bait i don't know what that means
weeb i like the chocolate puck what is
this a super chat i want it
i don't know if this is a super chat
um when did i start my channel um i
started it so long ago but there was no
videos on it um i started booktube in
earnest
last september um
didn't finish infinite jest yeah do i
read any philosophy
um i used to a little but not really
philosophy is interesting but it's it's
um
not my cup of tea always um
i don't know what a weeb is what should
i
what is my favorite sketch i've made oh
um i don't know
favorite one i made i like the one i did
with the pablo
um i also i like the one that i
doubt i just did because i i was
pretending i was twitter that was fun
um when there will there be more
avengers essay videos interesting that
was yeah that was my first one i did
even before i did booktube but that just
came out of nowhere and then i was
discouraged afterwards
and i just stopped trying but yeah that
was fun
video to make video essays take a lot of
time um but i do like that kind of stuff
i really do and if people are interested
in more like video essay like
media criticism analysis i love watching
that kind of stuff and i would love to
to make that kind of stuff you get gus
johnson vibes from my skit stump
sometimes i love gus johnson love love
gus johnson and i'm i
just steal like whole ideas from him
just relentlessly any sci-fi
recommendations for a beginner
sci-fi reader um i really love 2001 a
space odyssey
um or rendezvous with rama
um yeah i feel like those are
pretty good um are you okay
sarah asks
yeah i'm okay is brian sanders related
to bernie
um oh i didn't think about that maybe
taylor says congrats on 5k even though
you're not my dad i think you would make
an excellent dad thank you i'm a dad to
some dogs um
[Music]
yeah weebs are the people who really
into anime or manga
okay okay cool i like anime and manga
you obviously stole that pocky i heard
the sirens in the background they're on
to you
david david is admit please subscribe to
david destro he's he's amazing
i love david is this the couch from your
youtuber header yeah
actually in my youtuber header that was
when we were buying the couch
and i was trying i was laying on it to
just try to see if the size was right so
that's my youtuber header
video essays are awesome um
do i know about skip channel value
select no do i play dnd
i've never played it but i would really
be into doing that if somebody if i had
friends you know
um my favorite media analysis person to
watch
oh man so many i really love big joel
um lindsay ellis um of course
there's there's a lot i'm not thinking
of
where's the trumpet good question let me
go
your channel is like especially for me
tailored suit but for my brain
i'm glad i wish i could talk to you all
um
like in person i feel like we would be
very annoying to each other
i mean not like annoying to each i feel
like we would just be like if people
walked by us and we were all
talking people would be concerned
what do i think about the 2001 space
odyssey sequels also congrats on 5k
thank you
um i love the sequels 2010
odyssey 2 is probably the best one 2061.
odyssey 3 is
really good 3001 wasn't wasn't there for
it
uh what if my son turns out to be hoyd
that would be scary uh
i'd be really into if i have friends
jake 20 21 thanks mark
yeah i guess there'd be a lot of things
i'd be into if i'd had friends huh
uh we can be positive or negative things
depending on the contest
okay all right weeb cool
thoughts on dogecoin um
i have no thoughts on it it's it's like
the
the elon musket thing
what am i eating i'm eating pocky
um have i ever played disco elysium no i
don't play that many video games
you know what's funny i i don't play any
video games i don't have any like
i just i don't know i i haven't in a
long time but um i love minecraft and i
love watching like minecraft streamers
like
you know dream and stuff it's kind of
like my guilty pleasure
um pocky verdict
they're pretty good actually i mean
honestly i have such a bad sweet tooth
that i will like eat anything if it's
just there
um i have really bad like impulse
control with food so
i will probably eat it all um strawberry
pocky tastes the best that's what i
heard that's why i got this one
um do i like anime i haven't watched
enough to say but i will say yeah i
think so
uh from what i've watched
have i ever tried boba tea um yeah i
have tried it i'm okay on it but it's
not something i like seek out
um favorite game of thrones season i
have not watched game of thrones so i'm
just i'm gonna read the books
i think um am i excited about the next
update what what update is there an
update
is your new wife friends with debra
no they're really not friends at all
yeah it's like the elon musket thing
jake 2021
just keep quoting me i'm gonna i
has so many so many great ones all right
so what we're gonna do now
this is my trumpet i have not opened
this since probably
when i was in high school in 2015.
but we're gonna open it
yeah his my wife is friends with joshua
not not debra
um minecraft update
oh minecraft update oh yeah minecraft
the cave update
yeah for sure cave update it looks cool
if i like david lynch recommend serial
experiments
it's as if david lynch tackled the
internet in the 90s but
i love david lynch
uh twin peaks the return so good
what's okay so here's the thing i'm
curious like
who are who is the best director
or like everyone's favorite like
filmmaker or favorite movies like i'm
just curious
just to get a sense of what people like
i like david yeah
what color hair do deborah got
deborah got brown hair nolan
nolan is is that like i feel like
everyone's go-to
is nolan for like right now hitchcock
hitchcock is cool
i watched shadow of a doubt with my wife
the other day um
christopher nolan or denny villeneuve
yeah probably like working today i would
say
they're really huge right now
does michael like my new wife no
no he doesn't like anything he's a real
brat um
danny villeneuve yeah yeah anything by
dannyville new yeah i had a feeling
people would say that
i'm so excited for dune i am so freaking
excited for dunes
so excited um knives out is probably my
favorite film knives out is so good
oh man edgar wright and lynch penguins
of madagascar is the greatest movie of
all time
that's not even funny that's just sick
um
wes anderson is another favorite
scorsese paul thomas yeah i love
uh pta stanley kubrick
i really love the master that's a good
movie
gotta go congrats thank you andrew you
rock
all right do i simp for kaladin
yeah i think so tarkovsky is cool
stalker put me in a trance
tarkovsky i love tarkovsky i'm i'm a
huge
film buff that's what i originally went
to school for i love movies and i love
tarkovsky
stalker is amazing it's a it's like a
magical movie
um douglas sir cirque is great yeah i
love douglas circ
um written on the wind right that's a
good movie
uh i've not read dune but want to should
i wait until after the movie to read or
before
i don't know um it depends how you want
to experience it i think it's okay to
watch movies
before you read something if if you're
more preferential towards
you know that medium because it's just
you know it's it's whatever but if you
if you're really looking forward to like
a
an original experience with
you know with the book then i would read
the book first robert
roberto congrats you're great keeping up
thank you
my favorite director currently is ingmar
bergman never seen anything by tarkovsky
bergman
is cool bergman makes me sad though i
have to like
watch like a sitcom after i watch a
bergman movie cries and whispers is
really good fannian alexander is one of
my favorites
that's a really good movie um
almost missed the live stream thank you
for coming congrats i'm young and i
don't get poetry advice
go with that if you don't get poetry
just ride that wave
of not understanding it and just listen
to the words just read what sounds good
what like
little sparks here and there because
there's some poets that i love that are
my favorite that i
hardly understand but just the words the
language is just beautiful and i just
love it so
that's my advice whatever sounds good to
you
what are my thoughts on the dune books
messiah is great
congrats on 5k dark is the pinnacle
of sci-fi television okay
uh coen brothers are good nocturnal
animals
is one of your favorites yeah nocturnal
animals i i want to see that i actually
haven't seen that yet
um do i like the mandalorian
um i saw a few episodes but um i
i don't know i want to finish it i i
liked what i saw
but can i let me can i i let you out of
your basement i missed the sunlight
who gave you a cell phone to
how are you allowed to communicate right
now
can i beta read your writing um yeah i
mean when i'm ready to
like put it out there i will definitely
need beta readers and
um yeah i'm thinking maybe i'll do like
something through patreon i don't know
but yeah i'm very interested in that i
got to finish the book first though
i'm like halfway through charlie kaufman
is good
um i would say synthetic new york is one
of my favorite movies
it's incredible i love dark everyone's
talking about dark i feel like i need to
watch dark should i watch it
um tenet was great poetry is severely
underrated pablo yeah
just write what you're thinking will be
your poetry yeah absolutely
we have this sheen around poetry because
it's taught in school a certain way
and it can it can really be anything and
i don't think you should intellectualize
poetry too much
my voice is so soothing thank you oh
how did i acquire my voice
i don't know how does one acquire a
voice
um i've started listening to an
audiobook of dude and i love it
um that's great i'm really glad you love
dune
um with such a humor as yours can you
recommend a book that is very funny
um i haven't read a lot of
really funny books i don't know i guess
i don't seek out like funny
books naturally i can't think off the
top of my head but there are there have
been some
um i just started reading uh terry
pratchett i started reading mort
that was very funny um
um what genre am i writing did i read
lord of the rings i have not actually i
haven't even
i read the hobbit but i haven't read
lord of the rings yet i feel like i'm
waiting for the perfect time
i'm really looking forward to it though
yes watch dark definitely yes watch the
dark watch dark okay
okay just ask daniel green it's german
right yeah i don't know
poetry was done dirty in high school
that's so true have i ever ever read any
roka yeah i've broke on this
i really love roka really beautiful
i wish i could read german i mean that's
the thing about poetry is that there's
so much great poetry in other languages
i wish
i could just read every uh every
language because it'd be so much
better that way um
no there's not much of an audience on
youtube for classics um
but i just want to say i really love
those videos on faulkner and poach thank
you that's real thank you lorenzo that's
really sweet because i really have a
huge soft spot for faulkner and poetry i
do want to do more of those i mean the
thing is
yeah they don't get as many views but i
really enjoy it i love faulkner one of
my favorite writers and i love talking
about more
um stuff outside of fantasy too
um
i have i think i've watched an episode
of mine hunter yeah
um which books
most influence the book you're working
on okay and this is sincere the books
that most
influence the book i'm working on are
the communist manifesto
[Music]
stormlight archive
and the fugitive the movie the one with
harrison ford you know
he's like i didn't kill my wife wow it's
lap um
yeah yeah the book i'm working on is
kind of like
a magic system that involved that is
sort of like communist
um i just started more yeah
yeah i i really it's really fun
why do i think stephen king is such a
coomer his books are unabashedly horny
any theories on why because he's just a
horny dude i guess you know and he's
he's he's not a plotter so
there's no time to refine that he just
lets it all out and it's like
okay cool let's do it a lot of peeing
and pants
like a lot of like vomiting and peeing
in stephen king books i feel like every
chapter there's somebody who's like
wow that scared me so much i peed my pan
i'm like are you really
peeing your pants all the time because
you're scared
is it true that i'm a powerful witch
yeah i'm like wanda vision dark is
perhaps the only thing that makes me
proud to say that i'm german
um i haven't read lord yeah
i know no sir head canon
a lot of people are more better read
than i am like a ton of people
i haven't read a lot of things i haven't
read a ton of people i'm really new to
fantasy in a lot of books i don't want
to pretend like i'm some kind of expert
in fantasy um i just want to read more
and explore that and
i feel like this is a fun way to do that
um
okay yeah dark is cool all right i feel
like i've been putting it off yes karl
marx wins yeah for sure
carl is carl is amazing
all right so let's see what's in here i
haven't touched this since high school
oh no the valves the valves work
oh look at this
the valves still work that's really nice
german poetry really yeah really does
lose something in english yeah i believe
that
um i didn't kill my wife man carrying
thing
yeah clip that um for sure
back in my day it's the dragon lance
novels i haven't read a lord of things
either and only okay
here for the new fortnite content all
right
karl marx my grandma wow that's really
nice
your grandma was karl marx wolfgang's
channel yeah i'm
oh okay okay reading dreamcatcher now
vomiting and farting are literally the
two most important things that advance
the plot
in dream cancer catcher i've heard that
he's carrying i am carrying a trumpet
um finally glorious communist revolution
and fantasy i think this is what i'm
missing in my life yeah i
i kind of want to do something that's
not super um
like pro uh kings
you know kind of thing in fantasy i feel
like there's a lot of like um
too much monarchy in fantasy i would
love some like
real good communist like uprisings
that's really fun to read
you want to join an elf commune yeah
yeah all right well
let's see how this goes so this is the
mouthpiece
um god
i i have not played this in so long
you're not supposed to eat and play
trumpet you're supposed to like you know
wash your mouth but i'll drink some
water so maybe that'll help
um buy alien uh
okay and orc communist revolution would
be hilarious
yeah that'd be really cool powder mitch
is powder mage like that i want to read
powder mage
fully automated luxury gay space
communism
nice um
planning a world that actually has
democracy headcanon yeah that's cool
stop quoting me i would love some real
good communist uprisings
man carrying thing 2021 yep
but actually for real though all right
play for us the national anthem of the
soviet union oh god
what a glorious anthem i like to wake up
and listen to that
when i make the coffee all right
oh oh this is going to be not good don't
worry i won't play right into the thing
oh my god
that sucked
okay it's getting better the thing about
trumpets is that or any brass instrument
is that you gotta like
get your embouchure really tight like
that
and then because this is like the read
because like wind instruments you have
like a wooden
reed i mean come on brass players come
on rise up in the comments tell me
there's got to be some brass players
here come on um
i i heard i played brandon sanderson
stunt double in the mummy yeah
yeah yeah you're doing a medieval
fantasy novel in which the stock market
breaks down and drives feudalism with it
into the ground that's
hilarious i love that that is so great i
love that kind of stuff
oh wow fantastic start thank you
yeah baby steps baby step yeah so when
you don't
play brass instrument for a long time
your muscles here get super weak
and i haven't played in so long so it's
like really weak so it's going to be
really hard
clarinet gang let's go get out of here
claire if you play the clarinet i don't
want to see you around here i play
trombone for one year and then switch
clarinet no
why are people switching clarinet you
cowards
you're a brass listener because you're
watching me thank you
yeah stop quoting me jake oh man
you're just gonna keep clarinet gang
clarinet middle school ukulele these
days okay
you're here to stay baby okay joseph
whatever
clarinet people no this is not a
clarinet trumpet all right let's keep
going
let's see if i can play the uh the scale
i've still got it oh man
i've still got it that was really good
ha
i'm serenading everyone yeah that's
right
face reveal at 6k yeah probably i could
do a face reveal
the universe has a message for you
brandon writes faster than you can read
yeah thank you
gorgeous um i wonder how my dogs are
liking this i don't know
they're hiding from me i don't think
they like it
impressed applause thank you yeah my
lips hurt they feel like they're like
numb just playing that much yeah
yeah i was in a marching band i played
trumpet
and uh tuba i played tuba and marching
band
and it screwed up my back i walk at like
a weird angle now
um what chair was i i was um
for a lot of high school i was first
chair um and then
i was a field commander for my marching
band
my marching band they were mine no it
was cool though
we did competitions and stuff it was a
lot of fun marching marching and playing
an instrument is actually
harder than it looks jake i am
i am a man of many talents thank you
pablo i i try i try so hard
um congrats on you 5 000 subs yeah i
feel like i've already eaten 5 000
calories today
uh can i use it as my ringtone yeah for
sure
yeah i love how we went from eating
pancakes to this yeah
oh wait till you wait till you see what
comes next um
yeah it's 12 12 40 in india
and everyone's thinking i'm sleeping
while i'm watching a man carrying things
yes yeah india
being in india listening to me playing
trumpet i mean the internet is a magical
place i love this
played in the running band okay yeah i
you could definitely do a running band
my dogs are hiding from me
okay well they do that's too bad
good one first chair gig yeah first year
thank you stephanie but it's kind of an
elitist thing i don't want to be too
proud of that i feel like it's a you
know
you got to be nice to the second and
third chairs and whatever and heaven
forbid fourth chairs
um okay gotta go gotta eat pie okay bye
hugo
um all right yeah i love you buddy take
care congrats
you are awesome subscribe to hugo reads
he has a great channel really hugo reads
go do it um next up is the tuba god i
wish i had a tuba
i really did i'd be so glad if i had a
tuba
um i played contrabass tuba which is
like it goes on your shoulder
and it really screws up your shoulder
how do i stop every character from being
yourself okay
changing topic that's fine um how do i
stop every character from being myself
i'm still working on that
um i really don't know i i think that
you just have to like really check
because i think the the
the trick is like a lot of secondary
characters and like villains and stuff
when we write them we're like oh we love
these characters they're really fun to
write
because they're different from us and we
can see outside of them with your
main characters or protagonists
sometimes we're always in their head
it's we have to like try to get outside
of their perspective you know
and um you know that's really hard oh
we have some company i sedona
i sedona what
what hello hello
oh how's it going
it's sedona it's sedona
uh-huh yeah
yeah yeah she's really sweet
yeah she wouldn't commit war crimes uh
probably
i'm a fellow yeah well we haven't you
know we live in a a small place so we
need
i live in l.a so a small apartment
oh thank you kids that play trumpet in
high school are much cooler than the
saxophone players just kidding we're all
banners
we are all banned nerds but yeah trumpet
trumpets
we we're we're cooler than the sax
players i mean come on
um every time i see a dog i must audibly
state that's a dog yeah that's so true
is my dog the boss of the channel she
acts like it she really acts like it
um do i really write every day i
remember a video on ray bradbury you
made and i think it was one of his chips
i recall quickly yeah
i really try to write every day and it
can be super hard and i've been in kind
of a slump lately but when i'm really
going it's it's every day
i try every day but it can be so hard
especially when you have a lot of other
stuff going on but
you know i try
i try
something happened to his voice when the
dog came in yeah i got my cute
like sweet like loving dad voice
um she wouldn't commit war crimes
probably thank you head cannon
referring to us you did spell sedona
wrong that's okay it's sedona like a
city in
arizona i'm from arizona uh phoenix
arizona
so there's a there's a town in sedona
it's very beautiful
um vincent says saxophone
scores above everything is this the
vincent who is
constantly commenting about the stand
please say yes
i will not stop quoting you now that you
said you don't want to be quoted
that's fine that's i mean you got to
live with life i guess
you just kind of let let everything
happen
is joshua gonna take your dog too no i
would do anything
to make sure that doesn't happen um
do i know daniel green i do know uh
yeah arizona's super hot i do know
daniel green um
he's actually very nice even though we
talk about
you know lawsuits and stuff he's super
cool and um
he um yeah he just reached out to me one
time i had like
200 subs and he was like hey i like your
channel
um and whatever and i was like that was
really cool that was super nice i was
like
what it felt like you know people are
watching my videos that's crazy
and he's been really nice and supportive
um
the other pup's name is buddy um
we got him last year he's he's a well
they're both rescues but buddy
um he he was
very seriously traumatized he had a lot
of trauma and
didn't want to be around humans didn't
trust anybody but he's come a really
long way and he's really sweet
um arizona gang yeah
arizona is uh beautiful but
very problematic uh how do i save my
marriage i don't get why she left me all
she would say is that i needed to stop
talking about crabs all the time
and how crabs are the future of humanity
it just doesn't make sense
yeah you know that happens to all of us
sometimes we just start talking about
crabs too much and you just gotta
remember that not everybody's as
interested
in crabs as you might be but
to be honest if you've talked about
crabs that much already it's it's really
not worth
saving the marriage i would just let it
go
um yeah
what's that okay all right how is the
lawsuit going by the way
it's fine it's actually okay
um i think we might win yeah buddy found
humans he can trust buddy is super sweet
and he
you know he he sleeps now like in our
bed like between us and he's just the
sweetest dog
um rescue dogs are seriously the best
seriously
always do rescue animals um
bud does not trust humans because he
used to be joshua's dog and has bad
memories of them
maybe um
is the time near vincent yeah the time
is near for the stand
and oh they're walking around um so
vincent
oh hi sedona vincent has been um
commenting on my videos if you go back
and look at any of my videos
he's been commenting like literally
every video something about the stand
because
like i don't get it i don't get it he
talks about the stand like all the time
and
okay all right yeah it's
but it's interesting and and i love it
and i will read the stand
but i do feel bullied into it
um tell your wife that she's the future
yeah
congrat oh thanks pablo okay there is a
goblin here
i didn't even notice his name is donald
green
hi goblin thank you thank you for being
here and uh he did ask the question
favorite comedian um
um uh i don't know
actually i don't know
i really love john mullaney john
mulaney's really great
um but i think i think daniel knows
and loves gus johnson too gus johnson
has like the best
skit videos online um
yeah everyone be nice to daniel green i
will pause the lawsuit for the moment
don't
don't cyberbully him in the comments
okay just be civil people be civil
um no we're not gonna fight right now
when vincent when i read the stand
vincent will just fade away like yoda
okay that's kind of sad don't do that
um
steve carell yeah
yeah i think daniel's case in court is
probably not great now that
he's um he's on my live stream
bus jackson is pretty good yeah for sure
uh john mullaney's the goat he's great
especially for his feminine hips he does
um what are the rings
i've seen the movies and i love the
movies bo
burnham yeah i love bo burnham oh my god
he's amazing and he has a new stand-up
coming out soon i think i really need to
watch that
yeah i have i love comedy i'm really
interested in comedy
and um comedians and and all that stuff
i love stand-up i feel like stand-up is
like the hardest thing in the world to
do probably um
[Music]
like i mean you have to really like to
to do standard i mean people think you
you just like go out there and tell
jokes and then you're just like
successful but it's like you just like
have a crowd of like two people and
nobody laughs and it's just like
really cringey and hard and difficult so
people who succeed in stand-up i have
crazy respect for them yeah bo burnham
is great
please read one piece should i read one
piece
i know lost in discovery is reading one
piece and so is uh donald
donald green um larry has opinions
congrats sir thank you so much larry
that's really nice
i feel like i'm like i feel like my
energy is descending a little bit
you know what i mean i feel like i feel
like this has been a really successful
live stream
i'm really happy
i mean i can keep going but i i do feel
like i need to like
drink my coffee
settle down a little bit pokey crash
yeah i still have pokeys
just gonna like there we go
uh this is actually more uncomfortable
you like yeah okay i like channels that
discuss cosmere brandon sanderson in
general
rating more popular yeah i really love
that i think
i really love the success of the cosmere
i think it's really good sign
please don't leave okay
i'll be here all day folks um
give me 30 minutes to rest um andy
kaufman
oh yeah andy kaufman is crazy andy
kaufman is really
great um have i burnt my copy of catcher
in the rye yet
no i do like catcher in the rye it was
really good but you shouldn't identify
with holden caulfield i mean that's
the thing like you can light catcher in
the rye but the point is you aren't
really supposed to like
supposed to sympathize with him but he's
a kid like you're supposed to
i thought that was a point um
congrats on 5k um yum uh congratulations
5k
maybe you could celebrate by reading and
reviewing thomas pension
is that i don't that doesn't feel like a
celebration to me that sounds like
torture
i mean pension is great but yeah i could
read
gravity's rainbow that could be fun in
like a painful way because it does seem
really difficult
new to sanderson so what is the cosmere
i don't know actually what is the
cosmere
cosmere's just the the universe that his
books are in
um
being serious i don't i don't know if
that was serious sometimes i can't tell
if you guys are joking or not so i i
kind of have to take everything with a
grain of salt
so i'm sorry but yeah cosmere are the
the books within
sanderson's universe this man has a
great cosmere reading order
uh on my channel i thank you i love that
video a lot
that was really fun to make anything
that requires as little brain power as
possible are really fun for me
just pure nonsense is really enjoyable
we've got to balance the serious stuff
oh you're totally serious okay i'm sorry
100 serious only 250 pages into the way
of kings
okay you actually thought we were
feuding that's really funny
that people thought we were feuding for
real
although um yeah on my on my video where
i reviewed um
daniel green's new new book reach a
piece and in the video i say something
like daniel greene wrote
the cosmere or like yeah he like you
wrote the cosmere assembly or that he
he was born in 1971 or something
and someone actually was commenting they
were mad they were like
his name was daniel green first off not
donald green also he was how could he be
born in 1971 okay
that's like impossible
i like comments like that
cosmere is the name of para parallel
dimension which only sounds kind of
interesting but my my speech is failing
okay here's the deal
i've been i've been live for an hour 25
i'm gonna go for five more minutes
and then leave it out on a high note and
then that's like a nice 90 minute like
rom-com you know like a nice good movie
length right
that's like normal sittable length
so do i believe in multiverse theory um
i don't really know yet
but i i want to believe that's for sure
um since rap stands for rhythm and
poetry who's the best eminem or emily
dickinson
eminem i don't know honestly um
this is the perfect well thank you um
all right so since we have okay now four
minutes left all right
here's something let's end on a high
note i may play trumpet again i don't
know i'm eating
these things again so i don't know um
send me anything you want me to say i
will i won't say anything
obviously but you know i'll say stuff
also if you have like any last-minute
questions or you want me to
to like um i don't know just just
just start spamming i don't know tell
tell me what to do
we got we got six minutes let's live it
up
5k celebration yeah say i love you
i love you
okay go to karaoke song now
okay oh so what's the nonna licking the
mouthpiece oh no
oh no give us your worst theories for
stormlight five um
it's gonna be like um
sanderson's gonna write himself into the
cosmere and it's just to be like very
meta
um seeing the course that was nice thank
you
say i i love no i will not say i love
moash that's no
nobody's going to clip that you can
include me saying a lot of really stupid
stuff but i will never clip that sorry
i'll never say it although i did kind of
say it didn't i
do a live every saturday oh i don't know
maybe
sing billie jean i mean if people are
interested do a dolphin voice
that was really bad i'm so sorry i used
to be able to do that but my voice has
gotten deeper since
um yo just showed up you meant great
skits thank you favorite king book
um i would say drawing of the three
gonzalo i'm proud of you
i'm proud of you do a cartwheel um it's
it's small place i i don't want to break
anything
no i didn't say i love moash
you people duet with daniel i'd love to
um you must answer before you leave why
your wife wants to jump to rhythm of war
without reading any of the previous
books that's a good question
i think um she wants to read it with me
and
she's crazy she's like actually crazy
she wants to read rhythm of war
before reading anything else
tell me why calvin and hobbes are worth
criminals if you have to ask that
then you are on the wrong side of
history already
one sentence review of 2021 so far
slow personally
um do a cartwheel i can't will there be
any
okay okay okay awesome channel deserve a
lot more subs thank you hello there
all right i keep saying i love moash i'm
sorry
i said it again
it was really hard for me apparently um
she left you for joshua yeah
my wife is actually crazy
oh no i'm in trouble now
i might need to okay
this isn't gonna be good but on 50k by
year end that's very
ambitious but thank you larry that'd be
really cool but uh
very very ambitious
i'm happy with with what we got i love
this community i love everyone who comes
here
to to chat and hang out this is like
the coolest thing okay this is going to
be my sign off i just want to say thank
you
to everybody you are all very fun i'm
really grateful to have you know this
platform and have
5 000 subscribers and people who want to
come watch videos and hang out and
my favorite thing is always reading
people's comments because you guys are
really funny and i i'm always
just cackling after i make a video and
reading people's comments
they are hilarious you all are hilarious
and you make me want to make
more videos and be even more stupid and
read even more cosmere
and sanderson and read more fantasy and
talk about it so
you guys are amazing thank you for being
here
um late to the game but you read nada
based on your recommendation yeah
nada nada is a great book jean patrick
manchette um
i'm really glad you like that um i will
keep carrying thing thank you lee thank
you overly average band great channel
subscribe to overly average ben he's
really great um
thank you everybody um yeah go check out
the patron if you can there's
funny tears there's like rick tier
it's all good but yeah
where do you put the compilation of me
saying i love much
just keep it out of the public site
no i don't care um yeah
thank you everybody take care bye and
yeah
see you at 10k or sooner i don't know
we'll see if um
you guys want me to stream more um this
was fun i have a bunch of cold pancakes
that i need to eat
and yeah see ya
bye everybody
i want to read your comments saying bye
first so there okay
okay much love
yes
all right okay i feel like this is
one of those like phone calls where
you're like with someone you're like bye
okay bye bye like you don't know who's
gonna say bye the last time
all right i feel good now okay we're
saying bye okay cool all right all right
all right all right
bye everyone i'm gonna go for real for
real all right bye bye
i